ici on dit que le moskva le navire
amiral russe a été promu sous marins
alors il y a deux versions qui
s'affrontent sur ce sur ce naufrage il
faut avec le moskva a coulé lors de son
remorquage
et bien les ukrainiens disent que ce
sont des missiles neptune tirées depuis
le sud depuis odessa qui ont touché le
navire qui ont fait exploser des
munitions et ensuite la mer la mauvaise
mère en mer noire et le remorquage ont
fini par faire couler le bateau les
russes eux et bien disent qu'il s'agit
d'un incendie qui a mis le feu à des
munitions et la mauvaise mère lors du
remorquage a fait couler le navire
finalement il n'ya que le début de
l'histoire qui change à la finalité
reste la même et c'est ça qui est
important le moskva a coulé le navire
amiral russe dans la mer noire a coulé
le navire qui porte le nom de la
capitale russe ces images du de ce
navire en flammes au milieu de la mer
noire et qui finit par sombrer et bien
c'est quelle que soit la raison pour
laquelle et le coulin finalement que ce
soit à cause d'un incendie à cause d'une
fausse manip une mauvaise manipulation
ou à cause de domicile ukrainien et bien
cette image est absolument
catastrophique pour le kremlin c'est
leur plus grosse perte matérielle depuis
le depuis le début de ce conflit
et cela peut contribuer à inverser le
rapport de force dans la mer noire alors
le moskva ce n'était pas vraiment de ce
bateau dont parts et les missiles qui
frappe l est et le sud du pays lui
servait surtout tapis anti aériens mais
c'était le vaisseau de commandement et
et ce qui est sûr c'est qu'effectivement
le le commandement le commandement russe
en mer noire va être désorganisé pendant
pendant quelques temps et puis et bien
c'est aussi effectivement ça va obliger
la marine russe désormais à penser un
petit peu à sa défense pas seulement à
son attaque d'autant que
il y a deux jours boris johnson
lorsqu'il était ici à kiev a promis des
livraisons massives de missiles
justement sous marins pour abattre ce
genre de bateau et si les ukrainiens
commence à couler les navires us dans la
mer noire les uns après les autres en
sachant que les turcs ont fermé le
détroit du bosphore et donc les russes
ne peuvent pas renouveler cette flotte
en mer noire et bien cela pour être ce
poids déterminant dans la suite de ce
conflit en tout cas en mer noire et
notamment et c'est très important pour
l'ukraine pour la défense du de la ville
stratégique de dessin autre élément
sylvain rousseau depuis le retrait des
troupes russes des localités qui un tour
kiev où vous êtes plusieurs enquêtes
sont en cours pour crimes de guerre
oui absolument les enquêtes alors ce
sont des enquêtes qui prennent du temps
ce sont des enquêtes dans les preuves
doivent être dûment documentés 1 il ne
s'agit pas simplement d'observer
quelques choses et de dire haut ce
cadavre que nous voyons là et en civil
puisqu'il est habillé comme ci ou comme
ça c'est donc un crime de guerre non
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça chaque chaque corps chaque chaque
cadavre doit être autopsié et les causes
de la mort doivent être dûment
documentés transmises aux autorités
internationales compétentes et c'est
pareil pourrait bien tout ce qui touche
tout ce qu'on appelle en crimes de
guerre c'est à dire les actes de torture
ou encore les viols il y en a eu pour
l'instant alors nous avons pu nous
entretenir hier avec ludmila dénis sauva
qui est responsable parlementaire pour
les pour les droits humains qui est
apparu devant les journalistes hier très
ému à nous raconter d d d histoire
absolument sordide / / / des viols
collectifs notamment qui avaient eu lieu
dans ces territoires mais pour l'instant
elle même reconnaît qu'elle qu'elle peut
on prouver que les autorités
ukrainiennes en reconnaissent 53 et
seulement trois victimes sont prêtes à
témoigner elle nous expliquait également
plein de colère que le plus compliqué
dans ce genre d' enquête c'est de faire
témoigner les victimes la plupart
évidemment souhaite garder le silence
après après ce qu'elles ont vécu et tout
cela va prendre beaucoup beaucoup de
temps mais pour l'instant c'est encore
compliqué à dire si s'il s'agit s'il
s'agit d'actes d'être systématique de
l'armée russe s'il s'agit d'actes
encouragés par l'armée russe par les
officiels par le pas par le kremlin même
et c'est exactement ce à quoi les
enquêteurs vont s'atteler maintenant